welcome back to on base live in your
bleach Report app I am mookie bets and
today is a very special day um I got my
uh my homeboy Freddy Freeman he's the
guest
today um and today is uh season one
finale of on base it's been a special uh
this has been a special thing for me
freder it's been a very special thing
and to have you on for the last episode
that as I told you yeah that's how I got
you on the yeah it does mean the world
to me yeah and so one day I just went
and talked to him cuz he said no he
didn't want to do this I think we're at
four months of saying no four months of
saying no and he didn't want to do this
and I think I uh I started to cry but I
did you know I tried to I pulled on his
heartstrings and I said Freddy it would
mean the world to me if you if you do
the last episode and he pinky promised
me I did pinky promise I Think We Kissed
our hands too on pink prom with the kiss
on the end
yeah once you once you pulled on my
heartstrings I you know I have to say
yes yeah yeah thank you thank you so
let's get into the show a little bit but
oh before we do I want to uh list off a
couple of your accolades seven time
Allstar 2020 NL MVP who came in
second or third that year I don't
know all right three times Silver
Slugger and the 2021 World Series
champion that's the most important one
that's the most important one that's the
reason why we play we got another chance
this year um but we'll get into that
part um a little later on so now we uh
we play the uh this game on base off
base I mean uh whether you're in or out
very simple game okay all right let's do
it J he elevated your
style are you on base or off base on
that um on
base before my wife came into the
picture so did I used to wear um so in
the minor leagues I was you know kind of
a square and didn't really do anything
and didn't have any style so when Jason
came along that was when Polo was big
back in the day and I was matching my
Polo shoes to the double XL polo shirts
oh that's when the Big T's were in the
Big T's were in so me and J were
matching pullos back in the day so yes I
at least had a little bit of style it
didn't look great on me it looked way
better on him but
yeah and then everything you see now
it's usually Under Armour head to toe or
my wife picks everything so does she
does she does she lay it out for you and
then you just put it on yeah you know
she does like the pictures of this is
you need to wear this with that and yeah
nothing ever is me cuz I have no
style and you don't want to take the
time to learn it no even in La all the
swag out here you don't want to well
that's why I have my wife she's perfect
at it she's great at it I we're all not
you then look great like you do but
that's what my wife makes me look
somewhat decent she makes you look good
okay all right shout out to chel yeah so
but Jason yes at the start yes on you're
on base on that okay yes on base what
about this you would rather hit a
walk-off home run in the WBC than a
walk-off home run in the World Series
and I think this comes from because we
all know we're the passion for Canada
yeah well we don't all know let's let's
kind of let's explain that let's yeah I
play for Team Canada and the w BC the
last two years cuz my mom and dad most
people just know my mom but my mom and
dad are both from Canada and I lost my
mom when I was 10 years old to melanoma
skin cancer so long SLE where why I wear
long sleeves every single game uh just
in memory of her so I but I I I think
yes hitting a walk-off home run for Team
Canada would be cool but hitting a
walk-off home run world in the world
series I don't know I keep seeing clips
of Max mty doing it here that I mean
that is as cool
right there but um yeah anything with
Team Canada and no matter what it is is
special just because of my mom's but I
think I would have to say hitting
aun I wanted you to speak on that yeah
cuz uh it was weird you know when you
say you're going to play for Canada yeah
I was like why is he playing for Canada
and then I didn't know the story behind
it so would you ever play for Team USA I
played for USA when on the 16 and under
and 18 and under when I was a kid so but
now but no no I think it's just more of
I do it for and I've met so many
wonderful people with baseball Canada um
you know Greg Hamilton who runs all of
that and puts it all together you got
Larry Walker who's our hering coach
there's just so many wonderful people
and we actually won a couple games last
time so I think 2026 we're going to be
coming for you guys you were saying that
Offspring all right angel in the
Outfield is uh is the best baseball
movie uh no off off baseall what's the
best baseball mov um my all three of my
my kids are watching the sand lot every
single night right now so really gotten
into that lately but um I'm a
heartstring kind of guy so I like Field
of Dreams and the rookie like kind of
like those kind of stories that you know
kind of mean something and when you grew
up in OC yeah I did and you were you an
angels fan growing up I was a massive
Angels fan growing up and so you you
yeah I grew up 10 minutes from Angel
Stadium so um most people says it says
Fountain Valley on but I I was not I was
born in a hospital I was there for like
two days in Fountain Valley but I grew
up in Orange um which is you know about
10 minutes from Angel Stadium um and
then my family moved to Villa Park when
I was 15 so we're which is the next town
over so okay we'll get so I grew up an
angels fan Garrett Anderson is my
favorite baseball player yeah g and
what's cool is I've gotten to you know
hang out with him play golf with him
been here so it's really not everybody
gets to achieve that dream and you did
and now you're everybody else's favorite
player okay so now last one okay cousin
Freddy is a term of endearment yeah from
Kenley your daughter yeah you're on base
on that yeah I'm on how when did that
start it started well it all started
when we flew to Chicago together last
season 2022 you slept the whole flight
and I um I think you held Ken the whole
flight I did hold Ken the whole flight
we we were playing with stickers and all
that kind of stuff so that's when it all
started um you know I babysitted for 4
hours welcome not every time she sees
you yeah now I get hugs and now we now
she's doing her modeling poses because
her fashion stuff is so cute so awesome
she she freaking loves you every time we
get on the phone let me see Freddy I
want fredd every time M facetimes with
his family and Ken like I have to get on
the FaceTime too it's really cool all
right so let's switch gears okay this
year um you're probably having one of
the the the better years you've ever had
I would say yeah um what would
you attemp test that too like what do
you what's been different this year than
other years
um I've been asked that the last couple
months of like why I've been and I
really don't there's no blue there may
not be a reason there really isn't um I
don't know what it was but you know
every year you do a little bit something
like last year I only hit 21 home rounds
this year I did a little bit more so
every Year's a little different um I
think it just kind of happened that I
stole a lot of bases so that's why
everyone thought this but I would say
it's just more of as I've gotten older
you just understand the player that I am
and who I am and I don't try to be
anything different um I have a routine
and approach to Everything I Do I mean
yeah like everything I do is really
planned out so um I think that's just
more of and um you know I get to have my
family I have about 10 15 family members
that come to the games every single
night it's pretty cool I don't want them
to see me I see you over there waving
yeah I don't want them to see me stink
so I got to try and play good every
night and then um obviously when you
have guys like you and other guys being
back with J ha they just push you to be
the best obviously you want to play as
well as you can and win as many games as
you can so I think it's just La brings
the best out of people and so do you
feel
like just Comfort plays a huge part in
someone like you because think about the
first year you still bald right the
first year you still bald but it was new
for you you know what I'm saying this
was all new for you and let's go let's
go through that like how was that how
was dealing with that change you know
nobody's really heard from cuz you know
you don't you don't like talking about
it but I'm your boy and I'm going to get
it out of you how how was it going
through that change you know you it's
really a mindset change yeah it's if I'm
you know I I I don't like change I
usually do the same thing every single
day um but yeah it was a massive change
for my family and I more of I was
thinking of like Charlie's baseball and
stuff like that like trying to get my
family settled into a new place but I
try to take a step back and realize that
people you know change jobs all the time
um it's just not me switching a job you
know so um I and a lot of people counted
on me to to do my job very well so um I
was able to compartmentalize pretty
right when I got to the field it was
easy to just put it off and go out there
and play play baseball but um you know
it was a huge change um especially when
you know I was with one place for 15
years and then you're used to walking in
and knowing every single person and last
year I walked in that first day of
spring training and I didn't know 80% of
the people and you know that's it's
nerve-wracking it's uh it makes you feel
on edge uneasy and you got to learn um
the Comforts of other people too of more
of the hitting coaches what kind of cues
they can do for you um you know try and
understand Doc and how he works and then
get to know all the guys on the team too
so yeah it was huge but when you have
the front office you guys the coaching
staff and everybody that's associated
with the Dodgers wrapped their arms
around uh the Freemans like they did
last year it just made things
um a little bit easier to put our feet
on the ground as soon as we can but
obviously when we played uh the Braves
the first time and I got my ring I think
and we got to Colorado that next day
there was a huge weight off so you're
balling boom this year MH and you got to
doubles yeah and so every at bat where I
I know that you weren't necessarily
trying to hit a double but in the back
of your mind you kind of know I one more
double I think it was more I needed one
more home run for 30 oh you know but I
wasn't you know I don't really try for
that and stuff like that um you know the
last couple weeks um I hadn't been
feeling that great at the plate um as
you know we I was yeah we were grinding
in the cage trying to figure it out and
I was just trying to feel good at the
plate so if I felt good I feel like that
would have came with it and it was just
like little flashers like I had the one
game in Colorado where I hit the hit the
Home Run and then hit the double but
then the next day it's like I can't
Barrel a ball and it was just off and on
and then I had that one game the first
game in San Fran I had the Home Run and
the double I was like oh we might we
might do it but then I got to the cage
the next day and I couldn't even hit the
ball I was like ah this isn't going but
5960 I mean it's just I mean everyone
loves round numbers in our sport in our
job job it's really cool but it's really
one double yeah it is I mean still a lot
of doubles I sat on 39 homers for like a
month for for about a month and when I
tell you I wasn't trying to hit a home
cuz to your point like if I felt good I
would have hit a home yeah but in the
back of your mind it's like okay there's
two weeks left yeah okay now there's 10
days left okay dude going to Colorado we
got to get one you got to get one in
Colorado do you leave Colorado like oh
man and then so it I was thinking about
29 home runs more than the 59 doubles
cuz I want you know that's 30 home runs
is kind of cool so 30 home runs is cool
done that a couple times and then of
course I sat on it but I only at least I
only sat on it for two days I'd rather
have hit 39 like
you oh let's I want to ask this cuz
people don't know this going through
this last month I remember cuz we ride
the bus together yeah to and from the
field I mean we're together all the time
yeah and so I see when you're talking on
the phone you're talking to your dad mhm
and people don't know like your dad
plays a huge role as really your hitting
coach still yeah and you're what what
year for this is this is my 14th year
14th season in the big leagues yeah so I
talk you'll call in Big Fred and he'll
come get you right yeah papa free is
massive and it's more of he is the
changes my mindset kind of a thing
like most people just see the big
picture and they see the 330 and this
and that and they think everything is
gravy but there is little stretches
during that course of 162 that man I
just I feel like I don't know how to hit
the ball I stand in the Box it feels
like my feet are in the wrong spot my
hands are in the wrong spot so most of
the time when I feel like that I'll call
my dad and say do you see anything and I
I usually talk to my dad probably five
times a week even if I'm going good or
not you know just I like to talk to my
dad him and I are real real close but um
he was actually here yesterday yeah he's
coming watching you yeah he was here
yesterday bring it up yeah I'll bring it
up he was here yesterday in the cage uh
working he said I look great and it's
just you know it's more of changing my
mindset of like oh I I don't think I'm
feeling very good my dad goes you look
great you know and but yeah I talk to my
dad five days a week good or bad and
he's still I um most people don't know
but in the offseason I hit at my high
school um in El Medina which is 45
minutes from here um and he still flips
to me and throws me batting practice and
it's just me and him out and his
shoulder does he have to get his
shoulder looped up or anything yeah so
we played catch and he he can throw 60
ft you know but we I mean we don't he
doesn't throw 60 ft but he can get there
but this was the first year he started
uh not throwing as many strikes and he
he was felt so bad but I had a good year
so we're going to have to try that again
but it's just more of the bonding time
and we've done that my whole life just
me and him on a baseball field hitting
and just having fun together and I don't
care as long as he can throw baseball
I'm going to do it even if he bounces
every ball to me so is that kind of what
you see with uh with Chuck like what you
Chuck is Charlie yeah Charlie uh I see
all the time you come out early yeah you
and you do this a lot like you come to
the field at least two hours before you
would normally get to the field if not
longer and you're out throwing batting
practice to Chuck yeah so I I I love
being a dad it's like my favorite thing
in the world and to create memories that
he doesn't even realize there memories
that are going to happen for him later
on in life
um to me it's everything to see the
smile on his face when we go out in
center field and he hits a ball into the
net here at Dodger Stadium and um that's
what it is for me it's kind of what my
dad did it wasn't just to do it to be
make him a better baseball player it's
just to do that for bonding time
together and um I got two two-year-olds
as well so it could be four hours here
before a game in a couple years um and
you know those days are usually pretty
tiring but um they're the most
satisfactory for me bringing my son to
the games do you when when you are
working with Chuck do you like actually
teach him anything or you just kind of
let him do his thing um so I I first
year a couple months ago was the first
thing I ever told him he kind of does
everything naturally pretty good and
this was the first year I told him to
put his elbow his back elbow up oh so
you teaching him to hit like this I
didn't it's not to be like me but um you
know cuz when kids sometimes hit their B
they're already their elbows down and
they have nothing to like get create
more power so now I have them
creating a little bit more and now he's
hitting bombs now he's hitting
homers okay let's go back to Young
Freddy young Freddy said you're from out
here yeah and uh born and raised out
here when what did you play any other
sports in high school young uh no so I
grew I played basketball all the way up
until high school and then I started
traveling uh for baseball which is
basketball is the first in September
here in high school so I had to cut that
out and then I played football for two
years when I was seven and eight years
old but back then you went off of weight
okay so when I was about to be 9 years
old my weight would have been for 14y
olds and my dad was like you was a
double strike were you on the line I was
the quarterback and a middle linebacker
oh yeah but then I would I would have
been getting hit by teenagers and my dad
was like you're not doing that anymore
um my family is a big golf family so if
you see my baseball swing the Finish
High two hands I think that's where I
got it cuz I played a ton of golf when I
was a kid but once I hit um ninth grade
it was just just all baseball
and that was just because you didn't
want to play golf or do anything else no
well Golf and baseball the same season
in our high school um obviously by that
point I was I mean you're so athletic I
feel like you would have did something
El yeah cuz I was on the varsity I made
the varsity team out of as a incoming
freshman so when I right out of eighth
grade I graduated in the summer of
200 gosh three yeah 2003 that summer I
graduated 8th grade in June and I played
with the varsity team at my high school
in Medina that whole summer so um I
didn't really have time to do anything
more other than that and obviously by
that time I just love baseball so much
that I didn't really want to play
anything else okay so then you're going
through and you started to um what
college did you want to go to oh so I
committed to Cal State Flor 10 oh I
didn't know yeah so I committed to go to
k why there uh because I was going to
live at home with my with my dad and I
was just it's 15
it's 15 minutes um such a pretty answer
yeah I was going to become a CPA my dad
owns his own CPA firm with his uncle
with his brother my uncle and I was
going to be a CPA and play baseball CPA
play baseball just like pops yeah okay
we like numbers you know I see okay so
go uh committed to go there and then the
Braves draft you yes and then what was
the first thing you bought when you uh I
bought an Escalade Escalade yeah and I
bought that I made my dad go and buy it
for me when I was in Orlando so I left I
got drafted in 2007 and I left like a
week later from after I got drafted when
I was still in school the draft was yeah
California you didn't graduate high
school till like junee oh wow so you
were at school when your name yeah I
still had a whole week of school left
you know senior trips you know going to
nasberry pH Farm out here and stuff like
that but I had gotten drafted so I still
had a whole another week to go and then
I left and so I told my dad dad I like
Dad I want I want an Escalade he goes
you can't buy a new one I'm not I just
won't let you do that you know so he
didn't let you buy a new one no oh he's
like why we can just get one that's a
couple thousand miles used and it drops
the price by half the price I said
that's fine uh but I said I want a lot
of
chrome I need a lot of chrome I don't
you know how some of them don't have any
Chrome on them the older ones I was like
no I need a lot of chrome I want Chrome
and I said I want to put 24in rims on it
did you oh you're darn right I did oh
man you have and you know what that car
is still in my family you know who
drives that who my grandma drove that
until she passed a couple years so my
grandma who was 80s she was driving 83
years old was rolling around vill Park
California 45 minutes 24 in rims in an
Escalade it was so great but now my
uncle has it I've kept it in perfect
condition you got to keep you got to let
Chuck that that's got to CH it's really
there's like 200,000 miles on that thing
now so but it's still rolling real nice
so way to go
Cadillac that was the first thing I
bought I came home and my dad nailed it
it was it was
beautiful okay so you're going through
the minor leagues yeah and you meet Jay
ha yeah so can no I had already met J
you had already met J so can you kind of
explain to everyone that relationship
because everyone says me and you were
close which we are right but you and Jay
were actually the OG's yeah so I met um
there was a All-American Game I don't
know what it is now or who puts it on
but like the underarm all amican but
back then it was the afflac all ameran
you know little bird you know yeah so we
were an afflac All-American um in San
Diego he was the first baseman for the
east team and I was the first baseman
for the West team and they put us up in
a hotel and there was a community room
that had games and uh you know Papa shot
and stuff like that so that's where we
all hung out before we went and played
and for some reason we went in there and
Jason and I just gravit gravitated
toward each other each other and we were
inseparable that whole week and um one
thing led to another we're going to
different little showcases throughout
our senior Year Jason and I are always
there together so kind of attached to
the hip at these things and the next
thing you know um you know eight months
later uh he's drafted first round by the
Braves and I was drafted by the in the
second round by the Braves so he took a
couple more months to sign he waited to
like the last day but so it's August and
I'm in Orlando and Jason um comes and
you know we kind of just you know stayed
together and hooked up and then he left
to go to Danville which is High Advanced
rookie and so he left me for a couple
weeks but then we had instructional
League together there and then we
decided in 2018 uh we were going to live
together all the way through and so 2008
we were in Rome Georgia we lived
together um then we got moved up to Hay
same day together so we lived together
in Hay um and then or no we got moved up
yeah High a in 2009 and then we got
moved to double a together and so that
was in 2009 and in 2010 and he started
the year in the big leagues he made the
opening day roster which was one of the
coolest things ever seeing that
conversation and him walking out and
saying he made the team was the coolest
thing ever but I started in
triaa and uh so which was in gwet but we
still lived together oh cuz it's close
so he had a he had bought a town home
and um we we lived together and I lived
at his town home but so he would go
south and I had to go north cuz and I
was like which pushed me you know I was
like I wanted to get there as soon as I
could so I played really well in Triple
A and I finally got called up and you
know it's just kind of those
relationships kind of like you and I
it's just easy um you know we have the
Mind same mindset on life and and and
our goals in in life and you know we've
been friends for 17 years he was a
groomsman in my wedding um so things
have just kind of naturally worked out
and when I did everything I could to get
him here this last year and yeah so take
me through that like when you've seen
cuz you kind of watched J's career is
the wrong word but time in Chicago
unfold and you cuz you were right there
were yeah and as you saw it kind of
unfolding and you got here and you saw
that the Stars kind of started to align
like what was how how did you go about
that okay so I went to when we went and
played the Cubs in
2022 um you know I went over to his
house and hung out and um you know we
were just talking and he was just kind
of talking about the situation and how
things you know he wasn't going to be
playing as much and by August of 2022 it
kind of came out that they were going to
move on and they were going to mutually
part ways even though he had one year
left so I immediately found Andrew
fredman and Brandon Brandon Gomes and I
was like hey Jason Hayward and I just
threw it out there and um we kind of
talked about him a little bit and I was
just I never talked about really the
baseball player Jason Hayward I always
talked about the person Jason Hayward um
because if anybody comes in contact with
Jason it's it's for me it's like a
life-changing moment for a lot of people
just the wisdom uh the care the love
that he has for each and every person
that he comes across and um you know
they accepted it for a little bit you
know and then but a month later I threw
it again you know I never stopped um
putting Jason's name on the on the radar
and by the
offseason Jason and I were talking every
single day I said how's it going because
they were starting to talk and um things
just kind of felt aligned uh and it was
just a perfect fit I just knew it was a
perfect fit and I'm glad Andrew and
Brandon saw the baseball player was
perfect what we needed to and I said no
matter what happens he's going to be
great for the young guys and for
everybody else and he signed the minor
league deal and then he came out here
for two weeks and um you know he stayed
at my house for a week and then he came
up here for two weeks and he immediately
took Miguel Vargas and Gavin L Lux to
lunch you know just things he he hadn't
made the team yet and he was just doing
things that is once you know him is
Jason and um you know obviously he's had
a great year for us this year but I
think everyone can attest to the person
Jason is
is by far what we needed in this
Clubhouse I think going forward yeah I
mean somebody like him and and migy to
be to be honest you just bounce things
off of him he's been through so much and
seen so much like it's like he's been
through life yeah he already been
through it and he's come back and done
it again for us you know he's just a
wonderful person and we're just so lucky
to have him with us so you guys are in
the big leagues together and you guys
are in the big leagues together with
like Chipper Jones and so uh who else
was on that team yeah it was like so I
got called up and we had Chipper Jones
you had Billy Wagner um you had David
Ross um Derek low you had like back then
it was like never you had like one young
guy ever you know very very rare to have
a rookie cuz back then you had so many
and then you had like some of the
younger veteran guys like Brian mccan
and you know like Chris Medlin Tommy
Hansen jier jurgons we had so many a
good group of guys but yeah walking into
to the clubhouse my first day I thought
I was going to throw up um I sat in my
locker and didn't say anything you
probably enjoyed not saying anything
yeah that was but Bobby Cox comes up to
me and he goes have you seen the lineup
yet I said no cuz I got there at like
1:00 you know like 6 hours before the
game started he goes you're in there bat
six I said what said I'm starting today
he goes yeah go get him free I and it
walked off I was like oh my gosh so that
that was pretty cool like I got to play
for Bobby Cox my first year and and then
all those other guys you know um Brian
mccan really took me under and Eric
kinsky was great David Ross just chipper
and all those guys were so good to young
guys when I first came up um that really
shaped who I am today tell me about this
story with chipper um there was a
ATV the the snow you got snowed in you
guys said n we ain't going to be you
stay in tell me about this so chipper
and I um you used to live next to each
other in Roswell Georgia uh it's about
3540 minutes north of Turner Field um
and so you know how we do a FanFest here
but back then it was like a caravan so
we went to different schools and stuff
um so we had gone to uh high school and
doing all this stuff with the kids and
but we got alerts that were like hey
it's about the snow um like we don't
know if we should continue to go but
they're like oh we got to go to Turner
Field because there's a lunch in that we
got to go and talk and ask questions so
we go and do that it's like
1:00 we come out and our cars are just
covered in snow it's just snowing and
that day everyone let everybody out of
work and everything all at the same time
okay so if you thought LA traffic is bad
Atlanta traffic when everyone's on this
on the roads is crazy so we lived about
40 miles from Turner Field so I had to
try and get home cuz they canceled the
last stop and it took me two and a half
hours to get from um the parking lot of
Turner Field to the highway which should
take maybe 90 seconds 2 and 1 half hours
just to get to the highway and then and
it wasn't like snow downpour it was more
of it was ice it was black ice on the
roads and they didn't salt the roads
there was no one was prepared for for
this and um so it took like nine hours
for me to get off of the exit of where I
lived 9 hours yeah cuz cars were going
it's a little Hill cars would go up out
gas and then yeah so I got 9 hours I
turned off uh the heat of the car so I
keep I I thought that would help keep
gas so then I got and I got to the gas
station which is right off of the exit
so I filled up and I still had like
eight more miles to get off the road to
get cuz we lived far off the road and
finally um there was peeing in bottles
you know what are you going to do you
know there's TMI yeah there was so much
going on trying to get home and then so
this is this is why I had to get home
cuz so we had a couple animals Chelsea
and I live you know we lived together in
in Roswell and she had a vet appointment
for our animals she left and but I had
the only key to the house so you had to
Hur and get home so she couldn't get
back into our house and um with the
animals and so she ended up going to
Chipper's house and staying there with
Taylor and his wife chipper and his wife
Taylor so I had to get home to get so we
can get the cat food and stuff like that
so I was just going to stay at Jason's
place if I didn't have to which would
have saved a whole but we got a story
out of it so finally I got to uh like a
shopping center which
was probably 15 minutes from the house
and I my phone was dying I had 1% left
and I was like I can't make it home I'm
just going to sleep in the car and I'll
try again tomorrow and um chipper texts
me and says where are you and I said I
don't know the exact location the
address but I took a picture of the
shopping center and sent it and then
boom phone died so that was the last I
had and I was just sitting there and
then um like 40 45 minutes later there
is a guy coming in camo on an ATV comes
and comes into the shopping center and
skids out like on purpose and and it's
chipper and full camo gear and he
brought a jacket for me he's like you're
let's go we're going home and so I was
in okay so it was a it was we were on
the the Caravan there like and um you
could see like I leather jacket and
pants and I had Lou Vuitton shoes on so
but the pants right there came up to
like kind of where my pants are now and
your ankles are probably bleeding okay
so it's like 20° and we're on an ATV and
he's going like as fast as this ATV can
go I am like like holding on to him for
dear life and uh we get back we get back
to his house I guess Taylor didn't want
him to go because you know kind of
dangerous and stuff like that but my
wife Chelsea was like go get him you
know go go get him and so um he found me
he got me back and I they had the fire
going I sat in front of the fire for
like 20 minutes cuz I was just shaking
and then we took my wife's car home and
we were able to get home but that is the
story cuz um Atlanta wasn't prepared for
this snow that's a great St it's a great
story and then that's how he showed up
look at I mean it's crazy and then they
made a bobblehead out of it and then we
had out of that yeah there was a bobble
of him and I both you guys on and then
we did a commercial he was driving we
were at Turner Field and he was driving
an ATV in Turner Field and good for him
he's all retired so he had nothing to do
CU he had been retired for like two
years so I mean it it was wild but I
don't want to ever go through that again
no out here you won't have to worry
about we don't have worry about about
that okay so speaking of out here yeah
we have uh we've been playing pretty
good this year and I think a lot of
people didn't really expect it from us
and I want to hear from
you why you feel like we have been
successful this year I have my own
opinion about it but I want to hear from
you why so you know I've I've seen I've
been on a little lot of different teams
and how to navigate through the course
of season I've been on a team that won
the World Series we won 88 games that
year last year we won 111 felt like we
had a juggernaut team and we lost and
then I've been on 97 lost teams so
there's been so many different ways for
me um I mean if you look at it from
start to finish we have Clayton Kershaw
is the only one in our starting rotation
that was there at opening day we have
four new guys and they're pretty much
all rookies rookies yeah and then um you
know I just think it's more of our
offense uh had was stable throughout the
course of the year and then our pitching
was going up and down and then all of a
sudden everything started to click
pitching relieving like the back of an
our Bullpen with braer and bazooka and
Ferg and Evan everything just kind of
started to come together and I think
it's more because of a the clubhouse
culture and atmosphere that we created
down there that everyone started to feel
comfortable and with each other everyone
learned their roles you add in Kik you
add in Amed just things that kind of are
not the massive piece that you just
throw into a puzzle it's the pieces that
you just fit perfectly into a massive
puzzle and for me when you have rookies
that take the step that Bobby Miller and
Ryan pepio and EMT shean from the start
of the season to where what they are
doing now it is drastic differences and
how they carry themselves on the mound
their Poise um what they're learning
every five days and obviously James and
his rookie season it's it's kind of
amazing his rookie season how he plays
center field and then obviously the
coaching staff in the front office
everyone pulls on the same string here
and you know I think we just have a a
lot of pieces and then you have
us being at the top and just every there
every day and it helps doc able to find
lineups that work for us and I think
it's just more of everyone
just five six weeks in the season just
realized like oh no we're really really
good we're we're a lot better than we
expected wa wait a second we're really
good you know and everyone and Spring
train was like oh we're not going to win
all these games the Padre's this and
that and you know you just kind you
block it out like we do but then you
start playing and then you know we were
playing 500 ball for like five six weeks
and then we caught fire didn't we win
like 15 of like 17 and then we were like
okay we're really good Micky Rose been
unbelievable at shortstop just things
just the defense our defense I know at
the beginning of the Season wasn't very
good and then the last like four months
of the Season our defense has been
really really good and then our pitching
followed it up and things just kind of
you know aligned and we just knew we
were good and we started playing good I
think and I think you know at the
beginning in Spring you know we lose the
talent that we lost it's hard to really
believe that you're going to be just as
good right and so I was on the other
side I had been here I mean I guess you
had been here as well but I was like you
know what the talent that was here and
we didn't win like I wonder how this is
going to be and then it was really to
your point the clubhouse that I think
that's kind of really what kind of
carries if you there was little clicks
going on we just sucked those clicks out
put you like everyone just was perfect
in our clubhouse I mean you lose Cody
and Trey and Justin who's been here
forever maxers or yeah like there's just
so many people that you've lost that
it's like oh how can they but you yeah
but you can't even we couldn't even try
and replace no you can't you can't
replace Trey Turner you know what I mean
I mean you saw what he did the last two
months with the Phillies and put them
into the playoffs too but it I think
it's just more of the clubhouse and then
the how close we got it just transferred
onto the field CU every one actually
cares about each other and when you pull
for each other and want each and every
person to be successful that's what kind
of happens on the field okay so in
playoffs here what team I think the
people want to hear what team would you
obviously every team is good we're not
saying no team is bad by team going be
hard every who who would you say Okay I
I I would not like to face them right
now well I mean we got the Brewers or
the Diamondbacks right so which starting
rotation
got G Merl Kelly or you got Corin Burns
and they just lost Brandon wood they
just lost that's the only thing but I
there's no really like pick your poison
in that it's always it's all going to be
hard it's just going to be a different
heart yeah it's there's no like you
can't say I want this team like there's
we're all in the playoffs there's six
teams from each like you're the best six
but I mean for us I mean I don't know
would you want to play someone you're
more familiar with as in the
Diamondbacks you've played them 13 times
you know how we know what to expect I
don't know or expect but we went 5 in
one against the Brewers so it's do we
there's no answer you can really give I
mean do you want to fly 45 minutes or do
you want to fly four hours so there's
always different Avenues you know like
is it easier on us to only have to go to
Arizona or do like with travel and
schedule so there's no there's no answer
you can really give give I mean you're
two great it's going to be yeah it's
going to be really hard if we don't if
we play our game I feel like our game is
good enough so that's we just got to be
able to control the outs don't give
extra outs and get the big hit so we got
to kind of uh fast forward a little bit
because you know we got practice yeah we
got practicing a little bit we got fans
coming today we got fans coming today um
we may have to get you on for another
you know 30 minutes depending on uh
depending on how
season I know we we'll see we'll see cuz
the people want to hear from Freddy
Freeman Freddy Freeman's the ma' so but
I do uh have a couple uh fan questions
okay let's do it couple fan questions
okay so who's the funniest teammate on
the Dodgers I mean I think we all have
to go with Miguel Roos migy R I don't I
don't know IFK is up there too though
but I don't know if that's the funniest
I think it's the most fun like he brings
the most fun out of everybody it's going
to be funny too it's going to be funny I
mean we're all laughing I mean he dances
four minutes before the game in our
Dugout he's
TW the water coolers so I and that's
also why we play so he keeps everything
loose we just have a good good group but
I would have to say Miguel Ro okay so I
got another question what do you think
about uh aun's 4070 season 4070 so think
about 4070 yeah I I I don't even know
how you could fathom a 4070 season
[Music]
um that means he's just running all like
he's running everything just running if
he stole seven bases how many times did
he run you we haven't seen 70 storm
bases in that long and then to but the
thing is I think what took him to his
the his the level that he's at is like
his strikeout rate has
dropped drastically and um so those are
just like balls in play now that's
better chances yeah so he's putting way
more balls in play I mean everyone knows
that he's one of the best players in our
league and he just put everybody
on on notice for like this might be a
yearly thing
he's that good and you know you could
see right when he came into the big
leagues in 2018 that this guy's going to
be special and everyone forgets like
2021 when we won the World Series we
would never have been in that spot
without him without him he had like a
th000 Ops all the way up until the O
Allstar break so um we we thought we had
no chance that when we lost him and I
he's been doing this and then last year
coming back from the knee you know I
think this is I don't know a 4070 every
year that's a lot to a l this is him
though it could be like a yearly thing
it's he's really an incredible athlete
and he's an amazing baseball player that
you know when we're done playing he's
going to be still going we get to watch
for a long time well I mean when you're
done I'll probably still still going
still got like 4 more years to go okay
so last question last question who is uh
Freddy's Co GM in fantasy well right now
I have it's me and our clubhouse
attendance the the clubbies yeah okay
and um so those they run it though you
don't you don't I he sent me a picture
Gabriel sent me a picture of our team
but um we're one and three and I have a
lot of questions right now oh yeah we
scored like 70 points last week right
wow it's just no that's un it's
unacceptable unacceptable if you're
going to be I'm going need any need
trades I asked for one thing and that
was because me and Mike Williams uh
receiver are really really good friends
but he just got hurt he didn't even he
didn't even draft Mike Williams I wanted
Mike that's all I wanted but didn't even
do it but yeah so we're one and three
right now we're pulling up the rear I
think it's all right all right you still
got time we got momes oh yeah you good
you're fine fine you're fine yeah you'll
be all right we'll be all right all
right so we got to head to practice Yeah
uh so I got to wrap um this is the
finale of the last episode I'm sad um so
I got to tell everybody bye um to the
bleach Report Team thank you U to the
ladies that have been here every day
Abby Jackie Audrey was on the team and
then she she decided to leave us so but
shout out to you Audrey Kelly H thank
you guys I really truly from the bottom
of my heart I mean it thank you guys you
guys have made this wonderful very
enjoyable it's fun coming to work every
day um you guys mean the world to me
guys behind the cameras thank you guys I
want to give everybody thank you um and
uh be on the lookout for season two see
you
guys
[Music]
yeah